building a strong powerful and durable
core is absolutely crucial for athletic
performance
injury prevention and general fitness
the core plays a crucial role in every
movement you perform
even ones that seemingly don't
necessarily involve it of course it has
a direct impact on anything that
involves talking or twisting or
scrunching up the body in a forceful
manner such as a back tuck or many
different kicks
but it also plays a crucial role in
stabilizing your body
and your spine so that you can exert
force through your limbs
stuart mcgill refers to this as
developing proximal stiffness
so as to be able to exert distal
athleticism
you can think of the body as a series of
kinematic chains that means rigid bodies
connected by joints in order to exert
force
through that system you need to make
sure that those
rigid bodies are indeed rigid when it
comes to injury prevention what's
extremely important is your core
strength endurance
if you think about it your core is
working all throughout the day just to
keep you upright and to help you walk
and move and of course those smaller
muscles can get tired over time as they
fatigue that introduced weakness in the
chain
and that then introduces the opportunity
for injury so we need to think not only
about explosive
power and strength in the core but also
about
endurance and being able to exert force
through the core and that stiffness
for long extended periods of time we
need to train the core for different
ranges of motion and planes of motion
it's not just about sit-ups it's about
rotational strength and it's about
moving the opposite direction
in extension so we need to make sure
that we're covering all these bases
in our training which is something a lot
of people unfortunately don't manage to
do
so in this video i've compiled a series
of core
exercises that i think do cover all of
these important facets of core training
they're a lot of fun that are
challenging so let me know what you
think and
share some of your favorites in the
comments down below without further ado
let's get to it
[Music]
medicine ball throw
the medicine ball throw is a ballistic
exercise that allows you to develop
power against resistance
what i'm recommending here is the use of
a throw that has a rotational element
such as the shot put throw this will
train you to develop force through the
transverse
plane which is missing from so many
training programs rotational strength is
absolutely critical in the real world
whether throwing a punch wrestling or
opening a heavy door
the relatively low amount of resistance
provided by a medicine ball means you'll
be able to achieve a high velocity while
also going for higher rep ranges
that will challenge your explosiveness
and your strength endurance
cable punch outs cable punch outs are
another great move for developing
rotational strength
they're superior in some ways for
developing strength in the obliques and
useful movement patterns
as the resistance is coming from behind
you rather than above
which is where you want to develop the
power one armed cable row
with rotation this is a similar movement
only you'll be pulling rather than
pushing
pulling with rotation is a useful
movement pattern in real life see the
tug of war
which i'm sure is something everyone
does all the time but is seriously
underrepresented in most programming
a similar movement is the one armed
bodyweight row with rotation but the
advantage of the one-armed cable row is
that you're standing up
that means that you need to brace the
core and plant your feet to avoid being
pulled over
this makes a full body movement that
really challenges your core stability
and your ability to ground yourself
that's how you use your core strength in
the real world
hollow body holds hollow body holds are
extremely important for gymnasts but
they have a host of benefits for the
rest of us too
these teach you to contract and compress
your abs in order to achieve an
extremely strong and stable posture
that posture is essential for movements
like the planche and even the handstand
lie flat on the ground and draw your abs
into your spine while getting into a
posterior pelvic tilt
the small of your back should be
touching the ground and your shoulders
should be raised slightly
if you can hold this position you'll
build excellent core endurance not to
mention better
mind muscle awareness dragon flag the
dragon flag is an epic anti-extension
movement
popularized by bruce lee and later on
sylvester stallone
the aim is to lie on your back and brace
your upper body so that only your
shoulders are in contact with the ground
or the bench underneath
from here you slowly lower and raise
your feet and lower torso
keeping them straight and making sure
your feet don't touch the floor ab roll
out
the ab roll out is another
anti-extension movement and one of the
most challenging of all when performed
from a standing position
not only must you prevent the stomach
from sagging and touching the ground
whilst your hands are fully extended
you also need to contract the core to
pull yourself back upwards this also
involves the hip flexors and much more
lalanne push-up named after an absolute
legend of fitness the la land push-up is
an exercise that actually
is very similar to the ab roll-out the
difference is that you're using your
hands without the roller and simply
performing a push-up in that stretched
out position
it looks awesome and it's brilliant for
strengthening the core stretching the
midsection like this under duress is
amazing for stimulating a hypertrophic
response
and developing that six-pack look
lizard crawl the lizard crawl is a
movement i have come to absolutely love
as you may have guessed if you've seen
my recent videos
of me crawling around car parks the
great thing about the lizard crawl is
that it involves a continuous tension
and core rigidity
this is crucial as mentioned for
building resilience against injury
at the same time the lizard crawl
involves a rotational element as you'll
often have your weight on just one arm
and be forced to combat those rotational
forces
has all kinds of additional benefits too
like improved hip mobility
and because you can do it for distance
or for time it's ideal for endurance
and it's also just a lot of fun
handstands
the handstand is a surprisingly useful
tool for training the core
as much as anything this teaches greater
awareness of the core as you need to
keep it aligned
to avoid it toppling over whilst you're
upside down and everything's topsy-turvy
it actually becomes an anti-extension
movement in some ways as keeping your
core rigid allows you to lean slightly
forwards and then use your fingers to
hold yourself up
one armed shoulder press performing any
type of shoulder press with one arm
instead of two
will allow you to build core stability
as you fight the forces trying to bend
you to one side
there are other great advantages to this
kind of unilateral training as well
so i highly recommend that every now and
then you half the weight and remove one
hand
loaded carries i've talked about these a
lot but loaded carriers are so
beneficial that it bears repeating
again these are so valuable because
we're keeping the core braced for long
periods to build strength endurance
this is exactly the kind of scenario we
face in real life you can use loaded
carries with a heavy trap bar
by holding something over your shoulders
or by holding a weight in just one hand
called a suitcase carry and this again
adds that anti-lateral flexion element
similar to a side plank or a one-armed
shoulder press
put these at the end of your workout to
avoid fatiguing your core prior to heavy
lifts that could leave you susceptible
to injury
quasi-isometric push-up performed
correctly high rep push-ups should have
all the same benefits as the plank
as they force you to maintain a rigid
core even as you grow close to fatigue
problem is that a lot of people won't be
able to perform push-ups for two minutes
straight
or forget about their posture and let
their mid-sections sag
a solution is to use the quasi-isometric
push-up an extremely slow push-up
lasting a minute or more lets you focus
on keeping the core solid
whilst also providing countless other
benefits to add an anti-rotational
element
try performing these on just one hand
front squat goblet squat
so many programs designed to build core
stability focus on anti-extension
when actually a lot of injuries come
from flexion many of us spend most of
our day in flexion after all
and regularly need to lift heavy things
off the floor in front of us
of course sit-ups will help you to build
strength here but not strength endurance
performing squats with the weight in
front of you then using a sandbag a
barbell or
zercher carry for instance will allow
you to build that endurance and
use that core strength to keep you
upright even when there's a weight
pulling you
back down the other way medicine ball
slam the medicine ball slam involves
throwing the ball down from a fully
extended position
that starting position mimics the way we
often use our core in real life from a
stretched out
extension and it means that you're using
a fuller range of motion that can lead
to awesome and more impressive
hypertrophy
leg raises and frog kicks hanging leg
raises are amazing for training the
rectus abdomini as long as you make sure
to curl the stomach
rather than simply hinging at the hips
which trains the hip flexors
rather than the core add weight between
your legs and you'll provide the abs
with the resistance that is often
lacking in this kind of training
v-ups v-ups are an explosive alternative
to the sit-up or crunch that increase
the challenge and help you to generate
the kind of core power that you need for
explosive movements like tucks and flips
l-sit flutters i'm including the static
hold with a slight movement because it
is a fantastic endurance exercise
that will teach you to breathe through a
braced core and will build thick
powerful looking abs in no time
you really feel this one give it a try
pike pulses
pike pulses involve sitting on the floor
with your hands by your knees and then
raising your legs
this teaches compressive strength
contracting the abs against the
resistance provided
by your own body it feels awkward at
first but it develops the kind of
strength and mobility
you need to perform v-sits and
eventually maltese sorry here
there you go guys that's a bunch of
exercises designed to help you build a
stronger
more powerful more athletic core and as
an added bonus it'll also build
rip looking abs let me know in the
comments down below what some of your
favorite core exercises are
and if you enjoy this kind of list
format then i might do more like this in
future
if you enjoy this kind of cross modal
training that's for more than just
aesthetics then you might like my ebook
and training program
super functional training there i
explore all kinds of different aspects
of training from mobility to
endurance to strength and explosiveness
to brain training
and then combine it all into a single
program that you can use at the end
you can find a link to that in the
description down below and there's a
discount on right now whilst we're all
in lockdown
also a huge thank you to my patreons who
support this channel and help make it a
reality
i'm going to be showing a list of their
names here your kind support has enabled
me to invest in better equipment
and to spend more time working on this
channel so thank you so much for that
patrons get access to some unique
content and are also invited to the
exclusive
bioneer group on facebook where we
discuss all aspects of training
provide each other with tips and support
and much more so if you're interested in
becoming a patron then you'll find the
link to that in the description down
below
as well whatever the case thanks so much
for watching this one guys
subscribe if you want more and i'll see
you next time thanks ton for watching
and bye for now
this
you